have you guys seen these cases by span
these have the Retro iMac G3 theme
they've got three colors Bondi blue
graphitees and Ruby this will fit your
iPhone 15 Pro and your iPhone 15 Pro Max
and as soon as you put this on I feel
like it is a blast from the past before
I open these up a huge thank you to span
for partnering with me on this video now
I unboxed these for the iPhone 10 like
when was this this was 5 years ago with
the iPhone 10 and this really takes me
back to the days of when I really
started understanding computers I was
just at that age where I kind of got it
I mean I had been using them for a very
long time but leading up to the iMac it
was such a revolutionary computer not
only for Consumer Computing but for me
as a person like so exciting my family
had a few iMacs in the days but I do
remember getting my grandmother her
first lime green iMac and it was the
most exciting thing ever all right let's
open them
up I can't believe how good these look
now I remember back on the iPhone 10
like those looked good but this is this
has taken it to a whole another level
like it actually looks like that's like
3D like when I look at this I don't know
if you guys can tell but it really does
kind of look like it has like different
layers like it really does have the feel
of the iMac oh and I love that they even
have a cutout here for the Apple logo
okay let's put it on can't even like I
literally feel like I'm going to cry
right now like I actually like the tears
I'm going to I might I don't I'm going
to try really hard not to cry and good
news you do have access to the action
button right here on the side so you got
your buttons and it is the most
beautiful thing I've ever seen like look
how great this is I even love that the
bezels kind of come up right around the
side so that when I drop my phone it's
not Landing directly flat on the glass
this is so great like you can still see
the Apple logo in there I'm so glad I
have the natural Titanium because it
really looks perfect with this case so
beautiful look at you ruby red let's go
the red looks so good too it's awesome
this is so exciting I'm just like gazing
at it like with just such Delight let's
put the last one on the graphite okay
the graphite is pretty sick I think this
might be the one that I keep on just
because it kind of really compliments
the natural titanium and it's such a
good vibe these also do have military
drop raid protection which for me is
very very exciting I've already dropped
my phone so many times and I've ruined I
love that this is super adorable so this
will be able to withstand all the things
that I will probably accidentally put it
through so here's all three of the cases
all lined up look how good they look
this is definitely taking me back to the
future or well know back to the you know
what I mean if you guys want to get more
information about these cases I'll put a
link in the description where you can
check it out and a huge thank you to St
again for partner with me on this video
and once again I'm so glad that I could
share these cases with you because
obviously if you know me you know that
I'm a huge Apple fan and Apple has been
such a huge part of just my being a lot
of my content here on my channel is
Apple focused and for me growing up and
just finding apple and computers like it
really did kind of set me on this whole
other trajectory especially when it
comes to creativity even at a very young
age I've told all of these stories
before my mom was a teacher so we had
access to Apple Computers cuz at the
time back then like the only people that
really ever had Apple computers were
teachers and they had them in the
classroom and then they had the
availability to be able to bring them
home or purchase them so I'm super
grateful for that and my parents were
always very supportive of my weird
technology obsessions and and I'm just
so excited that now I can be here to
show you these incredible cases we're
coming full circle here like these cases
are really cool but everything that I've
been able to find and do because of
Apple it really has changed my life and
I'm just so appreciative that all of you
out there still watch my videos and I
love being able to create content for
you so oh my God I'm getting like
emotional interiored like why are you
making me cry I'm going to go I love you
guys thanks for watching and thanks
beegan for making these cases and
reminding us all that um it's okay to
think different